have you guys seen all the Twitter drama
lately all the diss tracks he said what
in that Chung oh my god Wow so
interesting he is reacting to the
reaction of that district and that
district that district I didn't like
that district as much as the other one
ah skydoesminecraft did what did your
bar drop that must say man hell yeah
Oh destroy I thought we were done with
these [ __ ] shitty diss track videos
didn't I tell you didn't I [ __ ] tell
you about the diss tracks you didn't
listen did you
oh you just had to make another diss
track [ __ ] cancer of youtube I can't
think of anything worse then he's
[ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] youtubers
being all like oh I can ride two words
together look at me my dick is bigger
I swear guys it's really big do you have
a small penis but my penis is a lot
bigger I sway oh you left our team our
artificial team on YouTube oh then no
one cares about anyway
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is all this [ __ ] stop it stop it
I don't care anyway today we're gonna
react to some of the reddit the Peter PI
subreddit last week actually guys
supposed to literally anything you want
I am going to check it out and it's
usually a good time it's usually a good
time let's have some fun starting off
with a respect women meme that's
incredibly unfunny thank you all right
what do we got here sleepy pie the
ultimate respect that's a pretty cool
fan er I actually really like that I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm looking at
but that's pretty cool hey we got
another one of these incredible I did
this with real-life paint stuff so cute
amazing talent I love it thank you and
it's always sister Pfister I don't get
it is that his sister he's oh it's like
Game of Thrones that's a great show I
need to watch it
I kept joking about me making a book
called how to respect women again
someone already did it a pure
masterpiece said by no one no one said
that but I still buy it you know you
would buy that [ __ ] don't [ __ ] lie to
me
dream tube a youtube dating simulator I
want this game please oh my god have you
seen the size of Jack's hands my god I
am into big hands so I'm into this game
look at marks Haynes
it's a goddamn giant hands I love it you
could do some sister fisting with those
hands if you know what I mean you know
what I mean you've dirtied a little
[ __ ]
hey where are you you know what I mean
[ __ ] you know what I mean thank you
for putting the Felix text there just to
clarify this meme in case you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] legit you can make these from
going to websites okay I know this took
zero effort just get out of here Netflix
plan to spend seven billion on original
content in 2018 your move Felix well I
know they're borrowing money to do it
right they're spending a bunch of money
no one cares basically yes I could
probably ask them to make me a show but
no [ __ ] that scare PewDiePie rest in
peace when you gotta make a youtube
video at 8 but you also go to prote okay
okay okay listen I don't want to see
this discriminatory racist memes anymore
okay I am sweet cut 64 now that's my
real name and this is how I roll
this [ __ ] is disgusting that's a brand
new display I don't know why that's it's
still disgusting I don't want to see
these filthy memes on my page okay
delete them delete them thank you
hey it's the nick Crumpton england it's
my city meme these are definitely not
getting old these are definitely still
really fresh
happy Anniversary me legs are so cute
thank you that's very nice I saw this me
and Marseille both saw this very cute we
had our six-year anniversary dabbing on
for each year
there you go you're welcome I'd said oh
yeah by the way squad fam oh oh you
stole squad fam from jacksepticeye cuz
he has it on his shirt listen this is
never stole it from me okay I have my
lawyer send a cease-and-desist to this
[ __ ] and this was his face afterwards
that's right hey these are good these
are [ __ ] good that Maine young one
with impeccable the fact that people
aren't paying commissioning me to do art
works for millions and billions it's
disgusting
disappointing pewdiepie night okay
that's pretty cool that's pretty [ __ ]
epic that looks legit you're so talented
you guys are so talented
PewDiePie channel 12 and uh you're just
so mean you guys are so mean you know
that guys I saw Jack spit I see wait a
minute enhanced on that photo enhance oh
my god what up squad Fame hey it's an to
go again
I know I am
I know anything's already
Pam flex begin squad
squeeze my fam I challenge you bros i
mean swipe back
a challenge for him
we'd like them to do anything clearly do
whatever the [ __ ]
my submissions as really dope thank you
and ago and day by day you guys always
impress me with your talent this is so
good when you have to explain your joke
what the [ __ ] is this image where do you
find all this [ __ ] he looks like a
whamon in that picture
thank you he said whatever you want so I
turned him into a wheel Thank You that's
awesome thank you thank you so much it's
this gimmick getting old this is legit
the fourth time I see this step up your
memes this is garbage
this boy besides that do you respect
women sometimes oh my god I have this
very subpoena PI meme going on right now
okay it's based on a video that I had to
delete because it got it got copyrighted
but basically it's me laughing at
Japanese anime I know I know no don't
don't click away yet basically me
reacting to Japanese anime where they
try to speak English and it's the
funniest [ __ ] I don't know why it's so
funny but look at this oh my god and
then there's of course this one
hello everyone hello Abele nearly hello
f91 yeah how are you fine thank you
[Music]
yeah okay PewDiePie 2017 man Imagi you
live expect women sister fit okay
whatever
what about the squad fam huh I think you
mean squad Fame squad fam we do the
praying emoji squad fam do you respect
women slip it is edible painting on
cookies wait you made a sleepy cookie
that's amazing
slapping slapping would you like it to
see this he loves it
portrait of Myers Ian okay I said you
can do whatever you want but it needs to
be related to me okay I'm the important
one here pay it daughter I am the one
that matters this is very cute by the
way I will make sure she sees it but no
hey pills check out the art for your
next line of merch hit up your boy zero
deaths that's actually pretty cool but
no PewDiePie and the quest for a good
content what do you mean what do you
mean are you not enjoying this video oh
that's right
be sure to leave a like by the way what
is up with my hair Jesus Christ whoa
that's actually [ __ ] good that's
really good what do you mean you tried
some all these humble ass artists it
looks like crap the Mona Lisa looks
terrible man come on this is good you
know this is gay don't lie to me explain
this Poots he was a Harry Potter fan all
along well you got me
JK Rowling if you're watching this a
yeah I hope you're happy
okay cuz I'm not a Harry Potter fan
anymore cuz you're mean
you're so mean you're a mean salty ass
[ __ ]
consider yourself not a fan I mean
myself whatever shut up shut up JK one
of these are not like the others
Jake
you snuck that one in there good job
good meme appreciate this beard has
turned my manliness and strength plus
ten at least
remember jar jar binks from Star Wars
this is him a lot of people don't know
this but hey it was me I didn't want to
admit it because everyone hates Jar Jar
I guess to be fair I am technically like
the jar Jar of YouTube anyway so have
you bought my merch yet all hail captain
sweet yes look at those muscles tell ya
wow that was another one of the reddit
PewDiePie submissions in the spirit of
all the cancer on YouTube make a diss
track on me best your next job is to
submit your diss track on me okay
bring it on suck ass cuz I will dad left
and right ain't nothing you can say
about me diss track me for the next one
make a diss track you have seven days
make it happen fam squad jujitsu thank
you for watching this video make sure
you do Jitsu and I'll see you bro us in
the next I I see fam squad in the next
video